HE JUST GOT A LOT OF
QUESTIONS.
IF YOU WANT TO GET IN SO BAD
WHY TAKE SO LONG.
JOE CONCHA JOINS US NOW LIVE
FROM THE STUDIO VERY CLOSE
TO HIS HOUSE.
JOE, FIRST OFF, IS IT
SURPRISE BEING HE GETS
POSITIVE REVIEWS AFTER THREE
WEEKS AGO THE TOUCHY FEELY
JOE DIDN'T EXPLAIN HIMSELF
TOO WELL?
>> SURPRISING?
IS THAT A RHETORICAL
QUESTION?
I BELIEVE IT IS.
YEAH, LOOK.
"THE VIEW" AMAZINGLY FALLS
UNDER ABC NEWS DIVISION.
THAT'S NOT EVEN SEEN AS AN
ENTERTAINMENT SHOW.
I WILL LEAVE IT THERE.
I WATCHED THIS INTERVIEW
TODAY.
I DIDN'T HEAR ANY QUESTIONS
IN TERMS OF WHO IS JOE
BIDEN?
HE HAS BEEN IN POLITICS FOR
NEARLY 40 YEARS AND I
HONESTLY DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
AT HIS CORE.
AND IN THE END, HILLARY
CLINTON MADE THIS MISTAKE
BECAUSE WE SAW THAT IN THOSE
CLIPS THAT YOU PLAYED.
AS A DEMOCRAT, YOU CAN'T
JUST SAY DONALD TRUMP IS A
BAD GUY, I'M A GOOD GUY OR
IN HILLARY'S CASE A GOOD
WOMAN AND IF YOU VOTE FOR
ME, THAT'S GOOD ENOUGH.
NO, PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW WHAT
YOU ARE GOING TO DO TO
IMPROVE THEIR LIVES.
WHAT'S THIS POSITION IN
TERMS OF IMPROVING
HEALTHCARE, IMMIGRATION, THE
OPIOID CRISIS.
IN TERMS OF RAISING TAXES.
WILL YOU RAISE TAXES OR NOT
RAISE TAXES?
WHAT'S YOUR POSITION ON
INFRASTRUCTURE?
AND SO ON?
SO I WANT TO HEAR THOSE
QUESTIONS.
I DON'T WANT TO SEE WHAT I
SAW TODAY.
I'M NOT SURPRISED BY IT
THERE ARE ACTUALLY TWO
REPUBLICANS ON THAT PANEL.
AND I GET WITH MEGHAN MCCAIN
WHY SHE WOULD WANT TO
ENDORSE BIDEN CONSIDERING
HER FATHER'S RELATIONSHIP
WITH MR. BIDEN BUT AT THE
SAME TIME, LOOK, HE IS GOING
TO HAVE TO DO SOME
INTERVIEWS WITH SOME TOUGH
PEOPLE IN SOME TOUGH PLACES.
HE EXPECTS TO BE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES AND
ANSWER THE KIND OF QUESTIONS
THAT I WOULD POSE AS I JUST
LAID OUT JUST NOW.
>> Brian: JOE, LOOK, HE HAS
BEEN IN THE BUSINESS FOR 28
YEARS.
I GET IT IT'S GOING TO BE
TOUGH.
MAYBE THE DECISION YOU MADE
IN 1984 YOU WOULDN'T MAKE IN
2019.
TOTALLY UNDER
UNDERSTANDABLE.
IF DONALD TRUMP TEACHES YOU
ANYTHING DON'T RUN FROM IT.
EMBRACE IT, EXPLAIN IT BUT
DON'T APOLOGIZE FOR IT I'M
NOT SURE WHAT HE IS DOING
ABOUT TWO CONTROVERSIAL
THINGS THE ANITA HILL
SITUATION AS WELL AS THE
TOUCHY FEELY TREND.
HE HASN'T REALLY APOLOGIZED.
HE ADDRESSED IT AND THE
OTHER THING HE DID, HE
MOCKED RIGHT AFTER HE
ADDRESSED IT INSTAGRAM
VIDEO.
SO FAR IN TERMS OF DAMAGE
CONTROL YOU CAN'T GIVE HIM
AN A.
>> OH, NO, YOU CAN'T.
HE HAS BEEN IN CRISIS MODE
FOR THE PAST TWO MONTHS.
BEFORE HE EVEN RAN, RIGHT?
AND WITH ANITA HILL, DOESN'T
ANYBODY ON "THE VIEW" OR
ANYBODY ELSE WHO INTERVIEWS
HIM GOING FORWARD, DOESN'T
ANYBODY FIND THAT COMPLETELY
DISINGENUOUS THAT ONLY AFTER
HE ANNOUNCED THAT HE DECIDES
TO APOLOGIZE TO ANITA HILL?
WHAT WAS THAT?
NEARLY 30 YEARS AGO?
HE HASN'T HAD THE TIME SINCE
THEN OR EVEN WHEN HE WAS
RUNNING FOR VICE PRESIDENT?
SO TO DO THAT NOW AND SAY
HEY, I'M RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT, I THINK I FEEL
BAD ABOUT WHAT I DID, I'M
SORRY.
THAT COMES ACROSS AS PHONEY.
WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED AT
LEAST FROM DONALD TRUMP
WINNING, BRIAN, IS THAT
PEOPLE EMBRACE AUTHENTICITY
GOOD AND BAD OR UGLY BUT BE
AUTHENTIC.
DON'T BE THAT GUY.
>> Brian: WHAT HAPPENED IS
HE PICKED UP THE PHONE AND
CALLED ANITA HILL A
DISASTER.
GAVE AN INTERVIEW TO THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" I
ESSENTIALLY DON'T ACCEPT HIS
APOLOGY AND HE DIDN'T REALLY
APOLOGIZE.
WHAT ARE THEY UPSET ABOUT?
HE DIDN'T VOTE FOR CLARENCE
THOMAS.
WHAT DID HE DO?
EVIDENTLY HE DIDN'T TELL THE
TRUTH ACCORDING TO HER WHEN
SHE WOULD GET TO TESTIFY.
IT WAS NOT GOING TO BE
FIRST.
SHE THOUGHT IT WAS LAST.
SHE WASN'T ALLOWED TO BRING
UP PEOPLE TO VERIFY HER
STORY.
SO JUST GO OUT AND EXPLAIN
WHAT YOU WERE DOING AS
CHAIRMAN A REPUBLICAN
NOMINEE AND MOVE ON BECAUSE
NOBODY WANTS TO RE-LITIGATE.
WE BARELY REMEMBER THE
STORY.
I'M NOT SAYING IT WASN'T
IMPORTANT.
BUT IF YOU ARE A POLITICIAN,
AND YOU HAVE A STAFF, AND HE
HAS GOT MONEY.
BE ABLE TO ANSWER THESE
QUESTIONS.
THE OTHER 19 CONTENDERS
AREN'T SEEING THE UNDEFEATED
HEAVYWEIGHT CHAMP RIGHT NOW.
>> AND GOOD FOR ANITA HILL
BY THE WAY FOR NOT FALLING
IN LINE AND DOING WHAT SHE
WAS SUPPOSED TO DO WHICH WAS
ACCEPT IT SO JOE BIDEN COULD
GET PAST THIS HURDLE.
FOR PEOPLE WORRIED THAT JOE
BIDEN IS GOING TO GET A FREE
RIDE FROM THE MEDIA, BRIAN.
HERE'S ALL YOU NEED TO KNOW.
BEFORE THE 2016 ELECTION 59
PAPERS, MAJOR ONES OFFERED
THEIR ENDORSEMENTS.
57 WENT TO HILLARY CLINTON.
TWO WENT TO DONALD TRUMP.
THAT GOT HILLARY CLINTON A
CONCESSION SPEECH.
SO THAT'S ALL YOU NEED TO
KNOW IN TERMS OF INFLUENCE
OF OUR MEDIA TODAY, AT LEAST
ON THE POLITICAL SIDE.
AND, LOOK, THE BOTTOM LINE
IS THAT AS FAR AS THE MEDIA
PUTTING THEIR FINGER ON THE
BUTTON FOR JOE BIDEN, WE SAW
IT, OBVIOUSLY, WITH HILLARY
CLINTON.
IT SIMPLY DOESN'T WORK
BECAUSE HALF THE COUNTRY
DOES NOT TRUST THE
MESSENGER.
IT'S ALL WHITE NOISE.
THE PUNDITRY AND THE
PREDICTIONS MEAN NOTHING TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY WILL DECIDE WHAT
HAPPENS HERE FROM DEBATES
AND A CONCISE MESSAGE WHICH
BIDEN NEEDS TO ESTABLISH
BESIDES TRUMP IS A BAD GUY.
>> Brian: JOE, I HAVE TO LET
YOU GO.
YOU UNDERSTAND HOW
CONTROVERSIAL IT IS GOING TO
BE FOR HIM WHEN HE DID NOT
KNOW HOW TO GREET THE HOST.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
SHAKE YOUR HAND, GIVE YOU A
HUG, GIVE YOU A KISS.
WE ARE FRIENDS WITH JOE
BIDEN TO WIN IN 2019, HE
CAN'T BE JOE BIDEN.
THAT COULD BE A PROBLEM.
JOE, YOU ARE RELEASED TO GO
PARTY AND GO TO THE CLUB
RIGHT NEAR YOUR HOUSE LIKE
YOU DO EVERY FRIDAY NIGHT.
APPRECIATE IT.